we've got breaking news for you this
morning from london about prince andrew
and the criminal sex abuse investigation
of his friend jeffrey epstein elizabeth
palmer is at buckingham palace with the
latest on this elizabeth good morning
good morning
the metropolitan police here in london
over the summer had a look at various
evidence in this case including evidence
coming out of a u.s civil court case the
one that virginia duffrey launched
against prince andrew alleging sexual
assault well now the london police are
saying they're dropping their
investigation
from the very beginning prince andrew
has denied the allegations i have no
recollection of ever meeting this lady
none whatsoever
but dufrese says this photo which andrew
has suggested could have been faked
shows otherwise and that she was forced
to have sex with the prince when she was
17 years old gail king spoke to virginia
jeffrey last year
he needs to be held accountable we need
to show the world that the rich and the
mighty can fall too
this scandal has made prince andrew the
queen's third child a royal
embarrassment
he's been withdrawn from official duties
and disappeared from public view he was
even missing from the family photographs
of his daughter princess beatrice's
wedding in 2020
queen elizabeth is now 95 and a widow
the royal family is working hard on a
seamless handoff to the next monarch
prince charles with a prominent role for
his son prince william and his
photogenic young family
you can see in this british radio
interview from august that london's
police chief
is treading carefully is he above the
law the duke of york no one is above the
law
in other words she's saying dropping the
investigation into prince andrew isn't
giving the royals a free pass
mark stevens a lawyer here in london
who's followed this case very closely
told me
that the metropolitan police concluded
that to make a criminal case stand up
here in britain they'd have to prove
that prince andrew knew duffrey was
trafficked and they just didn't think
that the evidence was there this doesn't
mean though that andrew's out of the
woods he has got to answer those charges
in the civil lawsuit in the u.s through
his lawyers by the end of the month nate
elizabeth palmer and london thank you